[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour deux
derniers dimba débats de ce dimanche
après midi avec deux circonscriptions
programme la cinquième du doubs c'est de
pontarlier morteau et puis la deuxième
du territoire de belfort et on commence
déjà par le territoire de belfort avec
moi pour animer cette demi heure de
débat voici la guitoune journaliste à
france bleu belfort donc en poste à
belfort vous êtes un spécialiste de
cette circonscription
et puis philippe piot journaliste de
l'est républicain de belfort également
nous rejoindra en deuxième partie de
l'émission pour parler plus spécialement
de l'aménagement du territoire voilà
pour commencer je vous présente la
deuxième circonscription du territoire
de belfort donc c'est belfort avec
l'ouest le nord et le sud de la ville
valdoie et giromagny
le député sortant c'est michel home
keller udi investit aussi par les
républicains qui se présente pour un
quatrième mandat
je vous présente également les résultats
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle sur cette circonscription
du territoire marine le pen est arrivé
en tête avec plus de 25% des voix
emmanuel macron en deuxième position
avec plus de 21 jean luc mélenchon
troisième position 20,3 % devant
françois fillon quatrième 17%
benoît hamon 6 2 nicolas dupont aignan
5%
je vous laisse voici la présenter nos
invités mais je me tourne d'abord vers
bruno kern qui est le candidat de la
république est en marche il a été le
premier adjoint aux finances du maire de
belfort en 2008 et ce pendant six ans et
c'est la première fois qu'il se présente
aux législatives en face de lui se
trouve michel zink keller le député
sortant sous l'étiquette udi les
républicains il est également maire de
valdoie on poursuit notre tour de table
avec maud clavequin qui est la patronne
du parti socialiste sur le territoire de
belfort
elle est également vice-présidente au
conseil régional de la région bourgogne
franche comté et c'est la première fois
qu'il se présente aux élections
législatives sous l'étiquette donc du ps
également présent sur le plateau jean
christophe lemur ringer qui le
représente
de vous la france le parti de nicolas
dupont aignan il n'a aucun mandat et
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il se présente
aux élections législatives enfin laurent
solaire qui n'a aucun mandat également
et c'est la première fois qu'il se
présente à une élection il est le
candidat de la france
insoumise devait être présent sur ce
plateau leïla le roi qui est la
candidate du front national mais elle la
candidate ne répond plus à nos
sollicitations
pourtant il m'avait dit par texto je
serai là dimanche voilà il faut que
j'ajoute donc la liste des autres
candidats présents dans cette
circonscription marc archambault de
l'extrême droite vincent judy des
écologistes nourdine les l'aimé cadets
du parti égalité justice philippe mars
aux divers jean paradis du pc et
jean-marie veulent pas de lutte ouvrière
à vous wassila d'ouvrir le feu oui je
commence par monsieur zoom keller je
vous avoue qu'on est un peu surpris de
voir sur ce plateau parce que j'ai
regardé un peu dans les archives de
france bleu belfort montbéliard et vous
disais lors de votre campagne de en 2012
pour les législatives que c'était la
dernière vous avez du mal un peu
peut-être avec les promesses les
engagements non après je les dis et je
crois que les temps aussi un peu changé
alors on peut estimer que c'est une
reculade pour moi ça ne l'est pas j'ai
une expérience j'ai 51 ans
les députés sortants n'auront 62 moyenne
j'ai 51 ans je pense encore pouvoir
servir
après est ce que j'ai la tête d'un vieil
homme politique est gris et replié sur
lui-même
moi je suis encore passionné par ce que
je fais je pense que les habitants du
territoire de belfort mairie de choisir
c'est eux qui vont choisir le choix
qu'ils feront sera le mien je crois que
vraiment on s'est engagé dans un truc à
quelque chose qui tombe et c'est paris
qui décide qui peut être candidat ou pas
alors je sais pas qui c'est c'est le
premier ministre il faut quitter c'est
justement
justement pourquoi ça serait décidée
comme ça pourquoi ça serait décidée pas
plus de trois mandats à autre chose
pourquoi ça serait décidé tout ça les
habitants du territoire d'iphone
connaissent mal leur choix sera le mien
s'il pense que c'est le mandat trouille
ils le diront eux mêmes par contre je
suis encore passionné par ce que je fais
je suis passionné par ce territoire et
je suis impatient de connaître leur avis
bruno kern
alors vous vous avez un parcours
politique que je qualifierais de
tortueux
vous allez pouvoir répondre vous
inquiétez pas vous avez été au ps vous
avez été proche des chevènementistes
vous avez été exclu du ps
aujourd'hui vous
tord marche pour un petit peu vous
suivre et déjà en 1981 vous étiez donc
vous travaillé dans des cabinets
ministériels
donc pour le renouvellement promis par
emmanuel macron vous n'êtes peut-être
pas vraiment l'homme de la situation
d'abord je vais rectifier et vos
informations
je n'étais en cabinet ministériel qui à
partir de 1987 dont 80 j'étais le jeune
assistant parlementaire de michel
dreyfus puis sénateur duffy tromper je
me suis trompé de maison mais vous étiez
déjà mal grand passionné de la politique
pas du tout j'ai toujours été avocat je
n'ai eu comme seul mandat comme ça
m'étonnait assistant parlementaire c'est
un vouloir alors je faisais mes études
en même temps je faisais mes études
après vous étalez entériné mise car
ainsi mes études
ensuite je suis allé au cabinet du
premier ministre qui m'a remarqué
lorsque j'étais candidat aux élections
cantonales en 1986 et à la suite de ça
je suis effectivement j'ai travaillé
auprès de laurent fabius ensuite auprès
de pierre bérégovoy et ensuite même
auprès d'un ministre gaulliste qui
s'appelait emile biasini dont j'ai été
directeur de cabinet alors renouveler ce
n'est pas le renouvelle ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas de la politique c'est avoir
des fonctions professionnelles et
ensuite je me suis consacré à ma
profession d'avocat et vous êtes
réveillés en politique ensuite
ensuite je n'ai jamais changé de parti
comme vous le dites j'ai été au parti
socialiste j'ai été en désaccord avec le
maire mrc devenu à la dernière minute
socialiste pour se faire élire étienne
booth bac j'ai accepté d'être sur une
liste qui était déjà une liste des
ouvertures progressiste à la demande
c'est vrai de mon ami jean-pierre
chevènement qui reste un ami personnel
pour des raisons je n'évoquerai pas sur
ce plateau mais qui tiennent plus à une
communauté intelligente laisse rien
d'ailleurs il me soutient et je n'ai
donc jamais pris aucun parti j'avais
même décidé d'arrêter après avoir fait
un mandat et puis rita est arrivé m'a
emmanuel macron et dès le premier jour
je les rejoins vous êtres à part dans
les premiers jours où adam voilà on mais
c'est là un mode de clark ans peut-être
mode clavequin snif c'est la première
fois on l'a 10 ans que vous présenter
aux élections législatives pendant la
présidentielle vous n'avez pas
franchement soutenu le candidat du ps
benoît hamon
vous avez déclaré sur france bleu
vouloir la réussite du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron vous êtes socialiste
ou la république en marchant je suis
clairement socialiste je lui ai toujours
dit ça a été ma ligne politique depuis
cinq ans depuis j'ai décidé de m'engager
en politique après avoir pris le temps
d'asseoir mon parcours professionnel
parce que c'est important d'être une
élue de terrain qui connaît le monde
professionnel et c'était un élément
central avant de m'engager je suis
socialiste je suis social démocrate je
ne m'en suis jamais caché une
investiture la république en marche à
vous gênez pas il me semble aujourd'hui
qu'il est important et c'est ce que j'ai
fait d'ailleurs de discuter avec
l'ensemble des formations politiques qui
peuvent incarner le rassemblement à
gauche la république en marche en fait
partie c'est en ça aujourd'hui que ma
ligne est très clair je défendrai
activement les valeurs du parti
socialiste mais je m'inscris dans une
logique de majorité présidentielle de
gauche qui m'obligera à être à la fois
constructives
pendant ce quinquennat avec le programme
des manuels macro mais à la fois
vigilant sur un certain nombre de sujets
qui sont importants pour nous tels que
la justice sociale monsieur solaire vous
vous représentez sur ce plateau la
france insoumise il y assure cette
circonscription outre mode kafka
représentants d'europe écologie les
verts lutte ouvrière le pcs que c'est
pas un petit peu bouchés à la gauche de
la gauche
écouter et apporter en fait écouter il
me semble que la france insoumise de
part son programme à venir en commun
reste actuellement le seul vrai parti de
gauche en france en me semble indéniable
la gauche dite libérale ou
sociaux-démocrates n'est pas réellement
une gauche puisqu'elle tend quand même
vers le consumérisme est toujours là
nous
on est à peu près certain d'être les
mieux placés les plus légitime pour
représenter la gauche en français sur le
territoire de belfort
c'est bien je vais vous demander wassila
de laisser la place à philippe piot de
leicester républicains comme je vous le
disais c'est le journaliste de l'est
républicain
l'un des journalistes de la grande
rédaction de l'est républicain à belfort
et philippa a décidé donc du choix de
son thème ferry vous avez la parole
alors en préalable je vais revenir sur
l'absence de la candidate du front
national parce que l'idée que je voulais
apporter c'est d'ouvrir un débat sur les
raisons qui font qu'une partie des
circonscriptions vote front national ce
sentiment d'être délaissés
ce sentiment d'être excentré d'une
france abandonné et aujourd'hui on
constate qu'à nouveau on a dans cette
circonscription une candidate fantôme
qu'on a pu avoir aussi aux
départementales comme l'a pu voir aux
municipales puisque certains candidats
du front national élu au conseil
municipal de belfort ne siègent jamais
en conseil municipal la question qui se
pose est ce que monsieur murungi et de
fait après dida d'union qui ne dirait
pas son nom
en étant debout pour la france mais je
vais vous poser la question est ce que
c'est une union qui ne se dit pas après
le désaccord entre marine le pen et puis
nicolas dupont aignan non faut quand
même comprendre qu'il ya jamais eu
d'union entre le front national est
debout la france de nicolas dupont
aignan il n'a pas fait l'unanimité dans
le mouvement je connais bien attention
la circonstance il n'y a pas d'accord il
n'y a pas d'accord le la corse était
d'accord avec le fait qu'ils partent
avec sur le principe je n'étais pas
d'accord après une fois que les choses
ont été lancées
une fois monsieur fidèles nicolas dupont
aignan je le connais depuis que je
connais très très bien c'est quelqu'un
qui a des cas d'une moralité en
politique à toute épreuve
donc il a voulu en vérité casser un
système politique qui empêche ont fait
de l'alternance dans ce pays depuis 40
ans depuis que françois mitterrand a mis
en place ouf enfin permis en tout cas
offert au front national de d'exister
pour en fait casser la droite en deux et
qui permettra la gauche en fait deux
de diriger donc donc c'est simplement
cette position-là d'offrir cas d'accord
sur la thématique il n'y a pas d'accord
sur les lignes bruno kern et à michel
zoom kenner vous êtes sur des programmes
que vous avez défendu à la
présidentielle qui prévoit des économies
et ses économies en partie vont se faire
sur des collectivités locales tous les
deux vous avez une expérience
monsieur zoom keller et maire de valdoie
monsieur kane a été non seulement le
premier adjoint chargé des finances mais
également de la ville de belfort mais
également le premier vice-président de
la cab et a dû mener des politiques qui
étaient dans le sens d'une baisse des
dotations de l'état
donc vous êtes sur des programmes on va
à nouveau baisser les dotations pour les
communes michel zink elle a redit que
nos rivaux nous l'expliqué et avec à
l'isi parce que le principe c'est de
s'exprimer si on en fait qu'il faut
quand même bien comprendre bruno kern
même clavequin soutenu gouvernement
françois hollande s'est pas faire injure
que de dire ça ce gouvernement massacres
et les collectivités locales
parce que là il à baisser les dotations
et sa empêcher l'investissement
résultat les collectivités aussi de se
débrouiller comme ils ont plus et
heureusement je me permets de dire à
bruno kern que notre majorité est arrivé
entre autres à l'agglomération
belfortaine pour reversée aux communes
des aides aux communes sinon on aurait
très certainement pas réussi notre
projet pas là des économies au niveau de
l'état très certainement il faut en
faire l'état de la période françois
hollande a fait des très grosses
économies sur le dos des collectivités
sans serait formé lui-même
on le voit encore maintenant maintenant
ils nous passent aux mairies les cartes
d'identité et les préfectures ne se
réforme pas notre souhait nous c'est de
réformer l'état et je ne suis pas
persuadé qu'avec un président énarque un
premier ministre énarque a misé de
l'économie énarque tous ces gens là
soient prêts à nous faire beaucoup de
simplification administrative et a
beaucoup réformer l'état qui l'a nourrie
depuis trente années ministre et les
républicains aussi à la premier
ministère républicain aura pas échappé
ou ça m'a pas échappé du tout seul ne
peut échapper je ne suis pas quand même
vous avez ce grand plaisir mais edouard
philippe ne représente pas les
républicains il a fait un choix qu'elle
allait répondre aussi répondre sur
l'aménagement du territoire parce que
cette nocturne du temps de la majorité
nicolas sarkozy les dotations ne
baissait pas bien sûr qu'elle ait fait
autant
annoncé blessé mais je voudrais juste
non mais beaucoup moins il faut être
clair elles ont baissé beaucoup moins
c'est françois hollande qui a massacré
des collectivités nicolas sarkozy la bce
et clément à condition qu'ils ne
glissent pas la peine je voudrais alors
peut-être apporter une information à
michel où mme keller là le mode de
fonctionnement des agglomérations dont
il fait partie d'ailleurs on a même
siégé ensemble fait que lorsqu'une
commune rentre dans une communauté
d'agglomération est là un retour qui
correspond aux impôts qu'elles
percevaient avant de rentrer dans la
communauté d'agglomération du vilain il
n'ya excusez moi il n'y a aucun
changement en termes de dotation de
reversement ce dont vous parlez ce sont
des projets spécifiques sur lesquels les
agglomérations est plus ou moins les
collectivités territoriales infondée à
ce fait oui mais ça ce fait vous ne
l'avez pas fait vous ne l'avez pas fait
les autres matches entre faire mâcon ça
se fait et si vous étés du député qu'est
ce que vous allez faire dans ces manuels
aaron hill a déjà dit deux choses la
première c'est qu'il baisserait les
délais la taxe d'habitation de manière à
ce que 80 % des français ne la paye pas
qu'il le compenserait qui est le
compenserait directement auprès des
communes ça c'est un premier point le
deuxième fois et voilée aux communes
elle n'est jamais effective jamais les
nerfs jamais ça fait 15 ans vous essayez
débattre vous voulez rester vingt ans
député apprenez à débattre je galère la
première des bad et aller débattre à
l'assemblée nationale où on vous voit
pas beaucoup
s'il vous plaît pas ce qu'il a dit que
son premier prix n'a pas dit son
deuxième et après on passe en mode cloud
deuxième point c'est je crois qu'il ne
faut pas confondre la ruralité et des
zones de campagne il ya quelque chose de
nouveau et c'est un diagnostic appose
emmanuel macron qui est important la
ruralité notamment dans le territoire de
belfort se sont pas uniquement des
agriculteurs qui travaillent en zone de
campagne
ce sont des personnes qui ont fait le
choix de vivre en zone de campagne et
qui veulent en même temps avoir des
services publics équivalents à ceux de
la ville alors je vais donner juste
aussi un lieu d'information et monsieur
keller d'avis à la dernière bien sûr la
différence de la taxe d'habitation sur
le grand belfort la plus petite des
communes d'angers la plus petite et la
plus petite taxe d'habitation aidés de
leurs deux quatre et demi pour cent la
plus grande taxe d'habitation elle est
de l'ordre de
18% si emmanuel macron décide de
supprimer la taxe d'habitation
c'est précisément pour supprimer cette
inégalité qui fait qu'à belfort et à
valdoie
on paye plus cher alors le rouge ajoute
et les pages et roumanie
mustapha khalfi la ftja est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que les programmes le
débat national n'a pas une tendance
quelle que soit la thématique on parle
de la solidarité
on va parler des quartiers des villes on
va parler de la compétitivité on a parlé
des métropoles c'est à dire on parle
toujours de zones qui ne sont pas les
zones rurales
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que le
vote front national dans la
circonscription où vous êtes candidat
et aussi ce sentiment que rien n'est
pensé pour des gens qui habitent
giromagny que ses lauriers desmons et
ses petits villages du nord de la
circonscription
il est effectivement une corrélation
très nette d'ailleurs des études le
prouvent 1 entre le vote front national
et l'absence de services publics sur un
certain nombre de territoires et
notamment de territoires ruraux concerne
entre notre circonscription
effectivement il ya des territoires très
ruraux je pense à l'ensemble du nord du
département
le premier axe que nous devons
impérativement travailler c'est
rééquilibrer les finances entre le grand
belfort qui est aujourd'hui un
territoire riche avec beaucoup
d'habitants avec une industrie et le
nord du département qui effectivement
depuis la réunification entre guillemets
avec la comcom voisine et bien se trouve
dans une situation très compliquée
financièrement et donc très compliqué
pour les citoyens ce découpage n'a été
fait sous un gouvernement de gauche et
aujourd'hui on a effectivement une
communauté de communes qui n'a pas de
ressources qui n'a pas d'industrie et
qui est totalement isolé là haut dans la
montagne je reformule les choses le
redécoupage a été fait avec les élus
locaux et avec amiens meslot
principalement qui a porté ce résumé 15
affaires représentant gouvernement donc
je me suis moi même je me suis moi même
opposé à ce redécoupage joly dit à
plusieurs reprises nous étions plusieurs
à nous opposer à ceux à ce redécoupage
parce qu'il est mauvais très clairement
pour l'avenir du département
donc la réalité est un élément
effectivement centrale et nous devons
penser et faire des propositions je
pense notamment au tourisme le tourisme
le ballon d'alsace nord du département
aujourd'hui a de nombreux atouts qu'il
nous faut mettre en valeur et qu'il nous
faut défendre de façon très concrète
merci
dan clarke à monsieur meyrin ge et
est-ce que vous avez donc le sentiment
que les politiques depuis plusieurs
années quel que soit le parti politique
au pouvoir
délaisse certaines zones du territoire
de belfort et quel est votre retour de
campagne sur ces localités que vous
traversez j'en ai clairement le
sentiment et je me retrouve ici
également ici dans un débat où j'ai
l'impression que par l'absence de ma ma
collègue front national je me retrouve
historiquement je me pince et les fêtes
qui font ça je me retrouve seul
défenseur à droite on fait de l'art de
la réalité et puis quelque part de la
france qui souffre puisque nous avons il
faut il faut pas le cacher des
thématiques en commun avec le front
national notamment qui des thématiques
qui discutent quelque part delà de la
prédominance de la politique française
au regard des politiques européennes qui
sont menées puis qui effectivement ne
vont pas dans le sens de la protection
des campagnes et juste complique terminé
parce qu'en fait j'ai pas pu parler sur
le premier le premier tour de table au
fond trois candidats
autour de moi sont favorables plus ou
moins à maquereau autres madame kafka
monsieur kern et monsieur une galère qui
a hésité plusieurs fois sera sous dix
agents n'agit pas la jouer oui ensuite
appuyons plus à fillon puis par derrière
peut-être macron peu vais pas raconter
n'importe quoi peut-être que macron le
mot le moyen de réunir la droite et la
gauche sur un grand projet fédérateur s
les séances à monsieur caire mais nous
nous retrouvons étaient sortants de la
primaire de ce point de vue là de toutes
les classes ouvriers finalement les deux
seuls défenseurs sur ce plateau ses
représentants la france sont pas
soumises et moi laurent solaire vous
êtes d'accord avec monsieur meyrin ge et
lorsqu'il dit je suis le seul défenseur
de la ruralité ça vous intéresse pas sur
ses conceptions sur 700 dans paris les
candidats soit ainsi bien sûr que ça
m'interpelle puisque moi-même c'est ma
spécialité la gestion territoriale
raisonnée professionnellement et du cou
on a vraiment à travers une fois de plus
notre programme les grandes lignes de
mise en oeuvre aussi bien en termes
d'autonomie énergétique d'autonomie
alimentaire et on est bien persuadé que
c'est au tour d'une économie solidaire
qui seraient éventuellement basé sur de
l'éducation alternative visant par
exemple à promouvoir l'altruisme à
l'avidité que on pourra dans les parties
nord très rurale recréer une économie
justement raisonnée et durable comme le
tourisme dit un mode car quand je suis
pas trop pour le tourisme j'ai cité
principalement la création d' autonomie
alimentaire et énergétique donc sur les
énergies renouvelables bien sûr et puis
également tout ce qui est réseau
d'économie campagne tourisme ça fait du
monde
le tourisme bien sûr le tourisme c'est
intéressant maintenant le tourisme je
crois pas que par rapport à d'autres
régions de france même si le territoire
est vraiment charmant je ne pense pas
par exemple qu'on puisse drainer des
flux touristiques aussi massive que ceux
d'autres régions françaises
merci beaucoup merci filet pour battre
donc demandé à wassila guitoune de radio
france de france bleu belfort de nous
rejoindre puisqu'il reste un peu moins
de neuf minutes dans cette émission et
avant de passer à la conclusion on donne
30 à 40 secondes à chacun des invités
présents sur ce plateau vous souhaitez
aborder à nouveau quelques points et pas
je commençais par bruno kern vous parler
de la ruralité vous dites la réalité ce
sont aussi les gens qui font le choix de
vivre en campagne et qui veulent avoir
les mêmes choses qu'à la ville j'ai le
sentiment qu'en disant ça vous êtes un
peu comment dire vous les critiques vous
êtes à la critique
non je vous trouvez pas légitime qu'ils
aient droit aux mêmes choses
absolument pas je voudrais simplement
répondre ici nous sommes candidats pour
être député
pas pour être président de
l'agglomération du grand belfort ou du
smiba qui gère le ballon d'alsace
donc je me permettrais de dire une chose
en tant que candidat à la députation
on doit savoir faire les bons
diagnostics sur ce que sont les attentes
des gens et précisément pour circuler
avec ma permanence buil beaucoup dans le
nord territoire permanence mobile il
faut expliquer c'est une camionnette
mais des normes et camionnettes cet
ardent ping qui s'est mis à table avec
des sièges et vous pouvez y venir nous
avons
mais mme bigot pour vous offrir à bord
c'est parfait on aurait bien besoin ici
simplement ce que je veux dire c'est que
les personnes rencontrées belfort vous
savez le territoire de belfort
ces 22 km de large 40 km de long par
rapport à la ville de belfort vous êtes
à 20 km quand vous êtes au maximum du
territoire de belfort
ça veut dire que vous pouvez vivre à la
campagne et travailler à la ville ça
veut dire très clairement que les gens
qui vivent à la campagne on fait un
choix de ruralité qui n'est pas
simplement l'agriculture c'est un choix
de vie je respecte ce choix je dis
simplement qu'il faut amener des
subventions et faire en sorte que des
projets que les collectivités
territoriales et les associations vont
porter c'est aux députés de ddc au
député ddc portée aux députés de faire
pour madame claf tient maintenant
quelqu'un que vous avez pointé du doigt
le fait qu'ils aient des inégalités
entre le grand belfort et la communauté
de commune des vosges du sud est ce que
pour vous il faudrait les mariées de
force
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui il est temps
de faire une pause sur cette question
des réunifications des territoires
administratifs
par contre il nous faut penser et de
façon très rapide
la question de la métropolisation à
l'échelle du nord franche comté
pourquoi je parle de métropolisation à
l'échelle du nord franche comté parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un bassin
de vie sur un bassin économique qui
fonctionne à cette échelle-là et le fait
de passer sur une structuration
administrative spécifique nous permettra
de façon très concrète d'aller porter
des projets et d'obtenir des subventions
européennes dont on ne peut pas
bénéficier aujourd'hui à cause de notre
taille pour justement aller défendre les
territoires périphériques
j'avais signé une tribune dans le monde
il y a quelques semaines sur la question
de la france périphérique
parce qu'effectivement je le dis le nord
du département a besoin d'argent a
besoin d'une structuration et d'un
modèle de développement qui soient
pérennes
je parlais du tourisme emile n'y a pas
que effectivement le tourisme est cette
logique de métropolisation permettrait
justement d'obtenir l'argent et de
porter les projets suffisant pour
défendre
les citoyennes et les citoyens de ce
territoire c'est là je me tourne vers
michel zumkeller vous dites ce
gouvernement massacre les collectivités
locales
si je reprends également précédent oui
c'est françois hollande
si je reprends si je vais sur le site
internet de des républicains cinq cent
mille cinq cent mille six cent mille
postes de fonctionnaires non c'est
toujours le cas pour les législatives
2010 est finalement c'est aussi un
massacre à venir moi je me suis toujours
posé la suppression de cinq cent mille
postes de fonctionnaires en tout cas
dans les collectivités parce que les
gens mais les légendes à l'agent qui
sont dans nos collectivités de travail
etc
oui c'est sympathique mais on peut même
pas s'exprimer registre à dire quelque
chose quand bruno quint décrit le député
j'ai un peu l'impression de me voir
parce que moi je suis sur le terrain
tous les jours dans les communes j'y
vais pas en minibus mais je vais
rencontrer tous les habitants je fais le
tour des 42 communes et depuis quinze
ans je fais ça on part on me dit il faut
il faut donner des subventions aux
collectivités pour faire c'est ce que
j'ai fait depuis 15 ans et c'est le
gouvernement des maynats de macron qui
veut supprimer les réserves alimentaires
parlementaire enfin petit ce prix met un
petit peu ou alors c'est c'est un
monologue bloquèrent fois que je vous
coupe excusez-moi la réserve
parlementaire
s'il vous plaît c'est vraiment pas la
hauteur des enjeux vous entends des
coups plus tard ma présence à
l'assemblée je me permettrai quand même
de remonter là dessus j'ai été classé
par jour nos capitales 91e sur 577 c'est
pas mal pour un député terrain qui va à
paris mais monsieur qu'elle va peut-être
plus longuement à paris mais peut-être
pas pour l'assemblée cet autre chose
je suis un député terrain qui fait son
travail et l'assemblée j'étais
rapporteur public en traîneau macron
j'étais rapporteur sur l'état d'urgence
j'ai fait 7 rapports en cinq ans cinq
ans et je les assume je suis un député
terrain qui est une activité
parlementaire reconnu et je n'ai rien
n'a changé à sa et toute façon je vous
le redis
moi ce qui m'intéresse ce n'est pas
l'avis de bruno kern c'est la vie des
habitants du territoire de belfort qui
me voient depuis 15 ans chaque jour à
leurs côtés le territoire le territoire
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
continuer à ce que la desserte du pied
sous vosgien alimente le nord le
territoire c est ce que monsieur macron
qui va mettre des enseignants dans les
zep va en mettre aussi dans les écoles
des territoires ruraux
je vais prendre un exemple de la
circonscription que vous ne que vous ne
connaissez pas puisque venait jamais à
oxelo à la rentrée je suis allée oui à
oxelo et je savais sûr
céret ou à la rentrée y aura une classe
de trente enfants avec trois niveaux
qu'est ce que fait monsieur macron pour
ça qu'est-ce qui fait rien parce qu'il
estime que les enfants ruraux
ils sont mieux traités merci serge stop
me suis engagé obligés de vous arrêter
reste un peu plus de trois minutes c'est
le temps de la conclusion monsieur
solaire vous commencez vous avez trente
secondes pour conclure allez on vous en
donne 40
si la cause est en retard au temps de
parole merci beaucoup écouté pour
conclure moi je suis déjà assez amusé de
ce genre de débat parce que en fait je
suis fait partie des insoumis c'est à
dire des gens qui sont conscients en
fait que toute cette supercherie là
depuis cinq ans tente depuis pompidou
giscard d'estaing et autres fait que
tout le monde converge vers une seul à
seul et même parti qui est le parti de
la finance et des banques
nous on veut plus de ça on aimerait
relocaliser l'économie on aimerait
recréer des micros emplois à l'échelle
locale et l'économie de demain nous
semble-t-il si elle se veut raisonné
doit aller dans ce sens eh bien merci
pour cette conclusion monsieur mûrs âgés
vous avez 30 secondes pour conclure ben
assez rapidement je restais sur une
conclusion assez politique parce que
j'ai observé comme je pense chacun
d'entre nous le contexte de cette
élection régionale
il ya les six noms de législatives en
inde c'est attire de nombreux candidats
à gauche je classe monsieur kern
évidemment dans cette catégorie trois
candidats à droite un député sortant qui
se présente pour la quatrième fois alors
bon t'as fait deux fois qu'il nous dit
que la politique ça doit s'arrêter un
jour préfère une fois ouais en 2012
excusez moi et puis une candidate front
national fantômes qui a failli youri
n'existera pas sur cette campagne et il
faut que je rappelle quand même aux
électeurs que c'est un candidat qui vont
candidats députés qui vont élire donc
tous les électeurs de droite je les
amène à je les appelle à se rallier à ma
candidature notamment la droite qui a
compris également que monsieur une
galère était quand même un petit peu
plus tôt centre secondes pour convaincre
aujourd'hui je présente ma candidature
au suffrage des citoyennes et des
citoyens de la seconde circonscription
du territoire de belfort comme une
candidature du renouvellement du
renouvellement réel du renouvellement
s'insère dans une logique à gauche de la
majorité présidentielle j'assume cette
ligne parce qu'il me semble qu'il est
important aujourd'hui d'utiliser de
nouvelles méthodes sur notre
circonscription d'incarner ce
renouvellement
ce n'est pas qu'une caisse
d'âge c'est une question de méthode je
suis sur le terrain depuis de très
nombreux mois de très nombreuses années
maintenant je connais très bien notre
circonscription on va laisser la parole
à messieurs zoom keller donc michel donc
à l'air votre conclusion
chacun pouvait terminer mais j'avais pas
de souci là-dessus maxime roy qui sert
maintenant vous savez il ya quelques
années les habitants du territoire
belfort m'ont fait confiance
ils m'ont confié un honneur absolu celui
de repli représente et moi je dois tout
alors je leur demande juste de choisir
le choix qu'ils feront sera le mien mais
l'histoire que j'ai avec eux c'est une
histoire de rencontre d'amour de liens
qu'on appelait tous ensemble et je
taille je sais qu'ils en sont conscients
c'est pas une histoire de document de
programme de campagne ou de choses qui
tomberait de haut comme ça sans que
personne puisse jouer dessus ce
territoire c'est un territoire que
j'aime depuis toujours
j'y suis tous les jours j'ai simplement
envie de continuer à être utile aux
habitants du territoire de belfort
c'est eux qui en décideront bruno kern
30 secondes je pense que tout le monde
ici autour de cette table m le
territoire de belfort
alors je laisserai la parole un électeur
de monsieur keller que j'ai rencontrés
hier soir lorsque je connais une affiche
il m'a dit michel zoom keller c'est un
très bon maire et je veux le garder
donc je voterai pour vous bruno kern à
la législative de manière à ce que le
cumul des mandats face qu'il reste maire
de valdoie et non plus député très bien
merci monsieur cad merci madame à merci
messieurs donc je vous rappelle qu'il ya
d'autres candidats en lice dans cette
circonscription marc archambault
d'extrême droite vincent jeudi
écologistes nourdine la paix parti
écologiste parti égalité justice
philippe marceau divergent parenti du
parti communiste jean marie veulent pas
lutte ouvrière les là le roi du front
national
ces gentils messieurs de quitter le
plateau madame aussi de façon vous
pourrez continuer de discuter dans le
couloir si ça vous dérange pas nous
allons accueillir les invités de l'autre
débat de cet après midi vous aurez tout
le temps de parler dans le couloir où il
fera beaucoup plus frais je vous assure
maintenant donc il est l'heure
d'accueillir donc merci à wassila et
merci à philippe piot de l'est
républicain maintenant il est temps
d'accueillir les candidats de la
cinquième circonscription eaux du doubs
cette quatrième débattent de c
deux journées j'en profite pour
présenter justement cette 5ème
circonscription qu'on appelle la
circonscription du haut doubs qui
concerne morteau et pontarlier
annie genevard députés des républicains
sortante et candidate à sa propre
succession
voici comment cette circonscription a
voté au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le 23 avril elle a placé
en tête françois fillon et c'est la
seule circonscription de franche comté
qui a placé le candidat des républicains
en tête emmanuel macron est arrivé
deuxième avec 22 % talonné par marine le
pen 21,7
jean luc mélenchon est en quatrième
position avec 13,7 pour cent
nicolas dupont aignan et benoît hamon
respectivement 6,4 et 4,1 j'accueille
donc maintenant david mal de l'ess de
france bleu besançon
et puis bon jour et puis donc nicolas
basse tuque de lester république à nous
rejoindra dans quelques instants pour
faire réagir les candidats sur les
francs les frontaliers voilà davini mal
je vous laisse je n'ai plus de voix et
je n'ai plus de salive pour présenter
nos candidats je prends le relai
catherine bonjour à tous avec nous pour
débattre sur ce débat de la 5e
circonscription du doubs annie genevard
la députée les républicains udi députés
parce que c'est la députée sortante elle
est également maire de morteau et elle
se présente une nouvelle fois sur cette
circonscription du haut doubs sur ce
plateau également est candidate à un
poste de député sylvie le hir la
candidate de la république en marche
elle est également conseillère
départementale du canton de valdahon
conseillère municipale et c'est sa
première candidature aux élections
législatives également pour débattre
avec nous anthony poulin conseiller
municipal de besançon il est le
représentant d'europe écologie les verts
dans cette élection législative
également présents et candidat jérémy
n'avions c'est le candidat du front
national il n'a pas de mandat pour
débattre également avec nous martin lui
dit la candidate de la france
insoumise elle est candidate donc pour
le parti de jean luc mélenchon et n'a
pas de mandat pour le moment evelyne
on en est également la présente evelyne
ternant c'est la candidate du parti
communiste et du front de gauche martin
evelyne ternant pardon qui n'a pas de
mandat voilà les six présents pour
débattre avec nous de cette 5ème
circonscription
et puis il ya également quatre autres
candidats en lice sur cette
circonscription à savoir yannick hardier
de l'upm et bagnols chats peuvent du
parti animalistes mais liam seringue au
de lutte ouvrière et sonia tatar enough
du mouvement m
100% david mal c'est à vous que revient
l'honneur le plaisir l'avantagent de
poser la première question et on va
commencer avec la députée sortante annie
genevard qui se représentent
annie genevard vous souteniez françois
fillon et son programme lors de
l'élection présidentielle pour les
législatives les républicains ont revu
et corrigé
le programme que vous souteniez est-ce
que c'était un mauvais programme
non ce n'était pas un mauvais programme
mais notre famille politique a tenu
compte du résultat de l'élection
présidentielle
elle en a conservé l'esprit et une large
partie mêlant à corriger certains
aspects je pense en particulier à la
l'augmentation de la tva ou encore
l'allongement de la durée la diminution
de l'emploi public ce n'est plus sur
cinq ans mais sur sept ans mais dans
l'esprit du programme nous sommes bien
dans la même ligne je dirais donc il
n'ya pas de reniement de renoncement met
une correction qui tient compte de
l'élection parce que les français ont
considéré que françois fillon n'était
pas ne devait pas être le président de
la république vous avez considéré que le
programme
il fallait de l'amendé il fallait
effectivement le corriger je pense que
si nous ne l'avions pas fait les
français aurait été en droit de nous
dire vous n'avez pas entendu le message
que nous avons fait passer donc qu'il
n'y a là rien que de très normal on se
tourne maintenant vers sylvie de lire
vous êtes la candidate de la république
en marche le mouvement d' emmanuel
macron alors vous avez une particularité
vous avez été élue conseillère
départementale au val d'arroux en 2015
sous l'étiquette ump
aujourd'hui donc vous représentez
emmanuel macron sur cette
circonscription
vous êtes la seule des poux candidate en
marche de droite ne sentais pas trop
seul
pas du tout et pour moi de toute façon
vous êtes la ligne vous êtes la limite
de droite du tout
emmanuel marquons notre président
incarne le renouveau c'est la
réhabilitation d'une france qui va
retrouver ses valeurs
c'est effectivement aussi l'humain qui
doit être au centre de ce mouvement
c'est un changement notre monde change
il y a effectivement un changement
économique
un changement oui mais vous en tant que
femme et de droite est-ce que c'est pas
deux bonnes raisons deux animés et bien
je suis du côté de la société civile
je connais fait en plus weezer la
japonaise voilà j'ai un petit mandat
effectivement le public ce qui me permet
effectivement dao excusez mon père je me
permets ticket petit mandat pour auxerre
départementale non mais là un court
mandat dillon voilà ça fait peu de temps
que je suis calme voilà c'est ce que
vous vouliez dire effectivement je dire
j'ai effectivement donc l'occasion de
débattre avec les citoyens et c'est
effectivement les citoyens c'est ce qui
m'a séduit mois dans le programme des
manuels mac on sait que ce sont les
citoyens qui sont au coeur de la
république n'avait pas répondu à la
question de 4e série
elle vous demandez est-ce que vous ne
vous sentez pas seul en étant de droite
et dans la public en marche
j'ai une équipe formidable et de toute
façon emmanuel mâcon il rassemble la
droite le centre la gauche donc de
toutes façons c'est un rassemblement
c'est un mouvement c'est une vague qui
donc que et porter et je me sens
justement très entouré jérémy n'avions
vous vous représenter le front national
les français n'ont pas voulu de marine
le pen comme présidente de la république
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle
est ce que vous vous considérez d'ores
et déjà si vous êtes élu député comme un
député d'opposition et je me présente
avant tout la responsabilité et par
inquiétude pour l'avenir de la france et
des nouvelles générations
au vue de l'héritage politique laisser
le système l'air ps à savoir chômage de
masse la sécurité précarité et quoi
centre ou expansions du fondamentalisme
islamiste
je me présente donc pour porter la voix
au sein d'une majorité patriotes mais
par marine le pen des 11 millions de
françaises et français qui ont voté pour
nous la présidentielle nous nous
opposerons en tout cas sans concession à
monsieur macro et
tous ceux qui prétendent vouloir
résoudre les problèmes qu'ils ont eux
mêmes cris maturité de patriote qu'est
ce que ça veut dire que vous pourriez
s'est justifié dans une majorité avec
des députés debout la france des députés
les républicains jeu c'est possible oui
après on part pour faire le meilleur
score donc du front national après
effectivement il peut y avoir des
alliances avec toute personne tout
député qui se définit comme un patriote
et son fils anthony poulin donc que vous
vous êtes un candidat europe ecologie
les verts vous avez aussi l'investiture
du parti socialiste dans cette
circonscription la gauche est
particulièrement faible
est ce que c'est pour ça que vous avez
l'institut recul investiture ps alors
concernant l'investiture ps ge et psa a
fait le choix de ne pas me mettre de
conduire en face de moi et je ne sais
pas si c'est pour cela que je n'ai pas
de contacts c'est surtout parce qu'il ya
une cohérence dix d entre nous j'ai
défendu le programme de benoît hamon
durant l'élection présidentielle dans
cette législative je suis le candidat de
benoît hamon et plus généralement de la
gauche et de l'ensemble des écologistes
je vous fais de la peine je vous
rappelle le score de benoît hamon sur
sept circuits et bien sûr on peut on
peut toujours regarder les scores de la
présidentielle c'est à dire que ça va
être exactement identique aux
législatives
moi je n'en sais rien je fais une
campagne sur ces valeurs là j'ai entendu
un certain nombre de deux personnes deux
jeunes intéressés par ces questions la
question du rapport au travail la
question de l'écologie que je met au
devant
dans cette campagne avec les questions
bien sûr des tic de solidarité et
d'europe
martin lui dit vous portez vous la voix
de jean luc mélenchon dans cette
circonscription est dans cette élection
est ce qu on a plant pas à voter
clairement pour le candidat républicain
et contre marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon n'a pas fait une faute morale
comme le dit bernard cazeneuve
non je trouve pas où est la faute morale
il a tout à fait appelé à ne pas voter
front national
ensuite libre aux insoumis de voter soit
macron soit ne pas voter soit voté blanc
le problème ne se pose pas en fait
mais il a clairement le problème qu'il
n'y ait pas un vote républicain qui
n'avait pas clairement à voter emmanuel
macron ça vous a pas choqué mais madame
est ce que vous
vous acceptez qu'on vous dise voter pour
untel moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi
il faut absolument toujours dire voter
pour untel il a laissé le choix c'était
soit d'un compte soit votre blonde soit
ne pas voter c'est clair evelyne ternant
donc on vous a vu arriver dont vous êtes
candidate communiste sur cette
circonscription vous a vu arriver au
dernier moment
est-ce que c'était pour rendre la
monnaie de sa pièce à la france
insoumise qui présente des candidats
contre les communistes à besançon je
pense notamment à christophe lime sur la
2e circonscription
les communistes ont recherché l'unité à
gauche nous n'avons à marcher à la
présidentielle n'avons pas présenté de
candidat nous avons soutenu jean luc
mélenchon et aux législatives
nous avons proposé partout et y compris
dans le doubs en france et dans le doubs
des ententes sur les législatives il ya
eu un refus catégorique de la part de
france insoumise qui présente
effectivement des candidats partout dans
le doubs nous joignant les actes aux
discours
nous avons retiré deux candidats sur les
cinq dans le doubs et aux france
assommée a maintenu les siens maintenu
les siens doivent être les rayons de
martin lui dit qu'il voulait répondre je
suis complètement surprise parce que
nous n'avons eu aucun contact avec les
partis communistes sur le doubs
alors effectivement au niveau national
il y a eu des débats entre la france
soumise de le porter communisme si on se
devrait vous inviter au moment des
campagnes les uns les autres pour que
vous vous posiez parce que visiblement
personne n'a les portables des uns et
des autres
non non je regrette je n'ai eu aucun
contact et même un banc la france a
soumises a quand même présenté ses
candidats depuis un certain temps et là
d'un seul coup on apprend que l'alors
fait qu'une réponse en 10 secondes et
oui nous avons cherché des contacts et
nous avons eu des contacts avec
françaises soumises dans le dos et il
nous a été répondu qu' il n'y aurait pas
d'entente que france a soumises voulait
être présente partout y compris la levée
par être entre vous de vie
on arrête là c'est bon c'est terminé
merci merci d'avoir participé à ce début
d'émission on se retrouve ensuite et
maintenant c'est nicolas basse tuque
donc de leicester républicain qui prend
votre place donc il souhaite vous
interroger sur les frontaliers ont
simplement la conclusion par rapport à
la gauche c'est que la gauche est
tellement puissante dans cette
circonscription qu'elle peut se
permettre donc de multiplier les
candidatures
allez-y nicolas c'est à vous les
frontaliers bonjour à tous l'occasion
d'y revenir après vous inquiétez pas
bonjour à tous tout d'abord vu de
l'extérieur votre circonscription fait
figure d'eldorado le haut doubs est une
région qui semble un peu béni des dieux
vous avez tous ou presque des paysages
magnifiques et donc du tourisme des aoc
et donc du grain à moudre pour les
agriculteurs un tissu économique et
commerciale assez florissant et surtout
15000 frontaliers généralement très bien
payé qui réinjecte lors pouvoir d'achat
dans l'économie locale alors est ce que
vous partagez
d'abord mon enthousiasme béant
s'agissant du haut doubs c'est la
première question est la question
peut-être qu'il est plus importante
envisagez-vous des initiatives
législatives pour conforter le statut de
ses 15000 hauts doubiens de 500 francs
comtois qui nicolas on va commencer avec
monsieur n'avions par exemple à
l'ensemble oui monsieur n'avions qui qui
a un discours beaucoup plus anxiogène
que cologna peut tout à fait d'accord
donc concernant les frontaliers tout
d'abord une fois que nous aurons
rétablir des contrôles aux frontières
nationales
nous proposerons la mise en place d'un
pass excusez-moi réservé aux
travailleurs frontaliers pour leur
faciliter le passage de côté français et
d'autre part nous avons que d'autres
propositions notamment nous souhaitons
revenir sur le droit d'option pour
l'assurance maladie
nous souhaitons aussi supprimé les taxes
aussi bien à tva que les taxes sur
l'importation des véhicules suisses de
société utilisé dans un cadre privé et
enfin nous souhaitons aussi supprimer
l'obligation systématique de de
présenter un contrat de travail lors
d'une réquisition de vaudois douanières
pour des raisons évidentes
ces biens techniques tout ça deux
raisons évidentes circuler la parole
madame jeanne var est ce que vous avez
d'abord le sentiment d'être une députée
vernis heureuse dans un dans un
territoire prospère et quelles
initiatives pour les frontaliers
oui c'est un territoire qui a énormément
d'atouts et moi je suis très heureuse de
le représenter et de et de faire dans
mon travail de député ce qu'il faut pour
et pour en améliorer la qualité de vie
et puis également tout ce qui peut
contribuer à améliorer sa prospérité
c'est un territoire sa particularité une
de ses particularités c'est l'adossement
à la frontière c'est vrai vous avez dit
environ 15000 frontaliers ça explique le
visage de cette circonscription en
partie seulement parce que un tiers des
actifs travailleurs frontaliers ça veut
dire deux tiers qui ne le sont pas donc
il faut se garder des idées toutes
faites et ce terme d'el dorado
je le trouve particulièrement réducteur
si vous voulez parce que il ya aussi des
difficultés le foncier cher les
impressions de créatures à concrètement
est ce que vous allez porter des projets
excusez moi je vous un terme un peu
parce que le temps presse
oui alors concrètement il ya un sujet
les frontaliers ont été assez malmené
par le gouvernement de françois hollande
emmanuel macron avec la suppression la
suppression avec la suppression du droit
d'option
et sur ce point je suis régulièrement
interpellé par les travailleurs
frontaliers sur la double affiliation
c'est assez technique en effet mais si
on parle de la sécurité sociale la
sécurité sociale ils en ont été
initialement privé et ensuite on a on
les y obliger et tout ça a été très
pénalisant à triple titre pour les
frontaliers eux-mêmes pour le territoire
lui-même qui en a perdu des ressources
économiques et je ne suis pas certaine
parce que le gouvernement n'a jamais
voulu s'expliquer là dessus que ça a été
une bonne opération pour les finances
publiques de la france
donc en matière d'infrastructures nous
avons encore beaucoup à faire
parce que nous avons
des infrastructures à améliorer sur le
plan routier et ferroviaire
et sur le plan numérique donc tout ce
qui pourra améliorer la fluidité du
trafic et l'amélioration de la prise en
compte mais pas seulement des
frontaliers jeudi avec l'ensemble de la
population mais verse de considérer ce
territoire que je défends le jeu plante
sacrée mais que vous avez épuisé votre
porte parole c'est madame le lire pour
la république en marche je connais bien
ce problème puisque moi c'est petit nom
j'étais fatigué j'étais frontaliers
mamelles il ya donc plusieurs problèmes
ce sont les routes là la route de
pontarlier est bloquée pendant je ne
sais combien de temps il y avait
effectivement un feu qui a été mis qui
ne fonctionne pas il ya eu une réunion
paraît-il à pontarlier où les gens
réclament un radar tronçon de la
commande de la clusaz passait pas la
clusaz ces deux entre joung et la gaufre
juste avant la clusaz et ensuite
sécurisé la partie de la clusaz parce
que c'est vrai votre premier point c'est
les transporte vous en avez d'autres
deuxièmement c'est la cmu parce
qu'effectivement pour payer la csg il
faut être assujetti la sécurité sociale
donc ma quand j'étais à l'époque on ne
paye et par la cmu par contre ce qui est
un petit peu pénalisant pour les
frontaliers
c'est qu'ils payent en fin de compte
leur csg sur leurs revenus frontaliers
et sur leurs revenus
également le revenu foncier en france
alors qu'il la paye déjà en france la
merci manager c'est la cotisation
chômage
je pense qu'il faut effectivement que la
le gouvernement se met en relation avec
la confédération helvétique
parce qu'avant en 1978 le la suisse
rétrocéder 90 % de chômage est
maintenant c'est selon merci madame mais
on va faire tourner largement une
supplémentation madame de 10 pour la
france a soumises sur cette question des
frontaliers
c'est le problème des frontaliers
vraiment un grave problème mais il faut
aussi une audience problème
ok pardon excusez moi non mais c'est
vrai qu'elle est les routes qui sont
envahis mais là on peut le régler par un
transport en commun ou favoriser le
covoiturage qui est déjà un fait mais
ils vont quand même considéré aussi que
certains vont travailler en suisse parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de travail ou des
travail à moindre coût au niveau du côté
français du doubs du pain du doubs du
jura des alpes et tout ça et je pense
qu'il faudrait comme le propose la
france insoumise augmenter les salaires
pour que les gens puissent vivre et
travailler au pays sans être obligé de
faire 50 km avoir des heures sa bouche
on sait que des gens à y travailler et
tout ça ne me choque pas du tout mais
variées voir ces travailleurs
travaillent mais je pense que certains
travailleurs préférait travailler à côté
de chez eux et ne pas faire des heures
et des heures de trajet sur une route
qui est quand même pas mal utilisé
c'est une fatigue supplémentaire donc si
les salaires par exemple si l'hôpital
embaucher un peu plus de d'employés de
le personnel soignant italie donc
l'hôpital de pontarlier où l'hôpital
public
les op est ce qu'un parlementaire
réellement le pouvoir d'augmenter les
salaires ça je suis toujours surpris
d'entendre des candidats en disant si je
suis élu le leu leu salaires ont
augmenté de 91 kg augmente va demander
on va demander son avis maintenant
élever une dernière c'est une voix juste
les internes pour le parti communiste a
bougé parce que la question frontalière
elle est un concentré du libéralisme
économique sans régulation parce que
d'un côté il ya une zone d'emploi
attractive la suisse parce que la suisse
est un paradis fiscal
quand une pas l'oublier et de l'autre
côté de la frontière une zone de
consommation et d'acquisitions
immobilières à prix peu élevés surtout
depuis que le franc suisse s'est élevé
en raison de la politique monétaire
suisse par conséquent ces disparités de
développement territorial effectivement
elle engendre beaucoup de problèmes d
engorgement de transport tout ce que
vous avez décrit
le patronat suisse profite de cette
situation faut quand même pas l'oublier
parce que les salariés français
permettent de tirer vers le bas les
salaires en suisse
il ya donc le dumping social qui
s'instaure en suisse donc bien au cif de
relatif mais qui existe les suisses s'en
plaignent et donc cela provoque des
tensions des tensions dans le territoire
français mais aussi en suisse avec des
relents xénophobes puisqu'on sait que la
votation sur l'immigration elle n'est
pas indépendante de ce système alors moi
je sur les propositions c'est clair agir
sur les paradis fiscaux
2 établir des conventions sociales entre
éteints parce que l'état est défaillant
dans cette question des relations
franco-suisses établir des conventions
sociales protectrice pour les
travailleurs et la protection sociale
j'ai été obligé de vous appeler roi
3une on va laisser la parole à un joueur
je termine une politique industrielle
une politique de réindustrialiser de
réindustrialisation sur le territoire et
des politiques merci à madame stern en
chocolat pour opérer ces couplets
materials a du mal entrevue entre les
deux dames allez-y allez-y alors
concernant
les frontaliers et globalement tout
toute la politique de connexion avec la
suisse dans le haut doubs le premier
enjeu c'est celui de la mobilité il y a
été posée moi je pense que la suisse
avec la région de bourgogne franche
comté pourrait négocier davantage de
choses concernant les transports
réguliers pour emmener tous les
travailleurs français en suisse
directement en transport collectif
il ya eu des efforts de fait sur le
covoiturage on peut renforcer cela ça
c'est sur la mobilité plus globalement
le constat était posée également le haut
doubs n'est pas simplement le
supermarché de la suisse n'est pas
simplement un territoire ont fait
l'acquisition foncière élevé parce qu'il
ya la suisse à côté et ça c'est un vrai
enjeu notamment pour le développement de
l'agriculture que de travailler sur
cette question de l'acquisition foncière
au meilleur coût et une question est
claire à madame genevard oui ou non vous
avait parlé de réforme du droit du
travail
allez vous voter le projet de monsieur
macron visant à assouplir le droit du
travail et naturellement c'est dans
notre programme donc les bonnes lois
nous lèverons les mauvaises manies les
combattre merci annie genevard merci
pour cette réponse très courte merci
nicolas donc on va rappeler maintenant
david mal pour la deuxième partie de
cette émission donc il reste un peu plus
de sept minutes avant d'aborder la
conclusion de 30 secondes par invité
david vous souhaitez revenir sur
certains points avec nos invités c'est à
vous je vais commencer par monsieur
n'avions vous avez dit nous on souhaite
rétablir les frontières
est-ce que c'est par un discours
difficile à tenir quand on veut devenir
le député du haut doubs où madame
genevard a dit il ya un tiers d'actifs
frontaliers a pas du tout il faut
rétablir la vérité
le contrôle aux frontières n'a pas
vocation une famille veut une vocation
de fermeture mais de protection et de
filtres aussi bien des personnes que des
marchandises est une autre question
cette fois-ci pour madame le hir vous
avez dit l'un des problèmes sur sa
circonscription c'est celui de la route
la route c'est une compétence
départementale vous siégez dans la
majorité départementale quand celle-ci
nationale donc c'est le seul problème
c'est la rn57 la nationale besançon
focal des 461 la des 437 mais ça c'est
départementale mais là où il ya vraiment
leur problème c'est au secteur de
pontarlier où une déviation devait être
fait
on en parlait déjà du temps d'edgar
faure il ya eu comme de l'argent de
débloquer qui est parti pour autre chose
et effectivement les mêmes les citoyens
trouvent une solution qui n'est pas
appliquée vous vous réclamez si demain
vous êtes député à l'assemblée nationale
vous porterez la voix les gens du monde
en disant il faut plus d'argent pour la
rn 57
disons qu'il y a des projets
effectivement qu'il faut faire pour les
frontaliers qui se sentent un petit peu
délaissé quand même en ce moment il
participe beaucoup à la vie économique
et c'est vrai qu'ils le tout le monde
réclament cette déviation de pontarlier
où au moins une amélioration une
amélioration avec ce feu
justement qui ne marche pas qui a coûté
250 millions d'euros
et puis sept ou huit cent cinquante
millions gilles les chiffres madame
genevard donc voilà j'ai les chiffres
hier qui m'ont été communiquées alors
justement madame jeunes vers vous vous
êtes à députée sortante
tout le monde connaît le problème des
mouches on du côté de pontarlier
est ce qu'un député et la députée que
vous avez pu être à la main peut
impulser quelque chose pour régler un
problème très local qu'elle ce problème
de bouchons et bien sûr moi il ya cinq
ans j'avais pris un engagement
l'engagement de relancer le débat du
franchissement de pontarlier et j'ai
tenu mon engagement puisque dès mon
arrivée
le gouvernement a accepté de relancer
les études pour le franchissement de
pontarlier et des études ont été
conduites et des travaux ont été
programmés à hauteur de 12 millions même
le lire qui est conseillère
départementale c'est très bien enfin il
doit le savoir j'imagine que la question
des routes c'est compliqué et que dans
le doubs il ya bien des routes qui sont
attendus et qu'il est difficile de ce
que vous êtes en train de demander ça
mais on a donné comme en mai à ce
problème en route il est un problème
majeur qu'il faut pouvoir continuer d'y
travailler mais travailler mais de
travailler ça dans je dirais des
perspectives qui sont raisonnables parce
que le contournement de pontarlier
aujourd'hui passerait par des zones qui
sont protégés donc c'est
réglementairement devenu impossible
exigerait un engagement d'un demi
milliard d'euros ce qui n'est pas
raisonnable pour un temps de trajet un
peu raccourcie donc il faut continuer à
travailler sur la sécurisation sur le
franchissement de pontarlier
parce que les frontaliers l'attendent
mais mais la population l'ensemble de la
population l'attend et avec patrick
genre nous avons contribué à l'or jeudi
à genève lé gen et vous avez là il reste
moins de trois minutes dans cette
émission
donc il est temps madame le lire de
conclure donc je vais courbes ou
proposer evelyne de ternant 30 secondes
pour conclure ses grands-pères bien donc
bien le message que je porte dans cette
campagne c'est le message du
rassemblement la gauche n'a pas fait 30%
tout candidat confondues au premier tour
des présidentielles
elle se présente divisée aux
législatives et elle est à reconstruire
et la reconstruction de la gauche elle
se fera sur des bases claires des bases
de rupture avec les politiques
d'austérité et le programme des
républicains comme le programme dans
marche sont des programmes de droite de
réduction des dépenses publiques
donc la gauche elle se fera en rupture
avec cela elle se fera sur un projet de
leurs madame ternant faut conclure j
arrive elle ne elle ne pourra se faire
sur ces bases claires qu'en réunissant
toutes les sensibilités
merci la sensibilité non celle là c'est
terminé pour vous merci martin deen vous
avez la parole 30 secondes s'il vous
plaît pouvoir parler du programme de la
france insoumise d'avenir en commun
quand même parce que le débat avec le pc
et puis les routes ça va donc pour nous
l'avenir en commun c'est simple c'est un
programme démocratique social et
écologique nous prévoyons la
planification écologique qui permettra
d'embaucher beaucoup de monde notamment
les gens qui se sentent obligés d'aller
travailler en suisse et qui pourront
travailler sur sur la région du haut
doubs et du doubs même donc cette
planification écologique une agriculture
paysanne et écologique
une santé d'abord et pour tout le monde
pour
on prévoit la sécurité sociale intégral
pour tous on abroge la loi elle comme
rit et on refuse les ordonnances merci
beaucoup
macro anthony poulin 30 secondes pour
conclure alors dans ses initiatives le
choix est assez clair dans le haut doubs
on a une candidate de la droite des
privilèges qui a soutenu françois fillon
jusqu'au bout on a une candidate de la
droite qui se cache avec emmanuel macron
on a eu un front national qui est sûr le
repli sur soi la division de la société
et il ya le choix de l'écologie
l'écologie c'est un choix qui n'est pas
uniquement pour les uns ou les autres il
est pour l'ensemble des habitants
l'ensemble des enfants qui sont nés et
qui naissent aujourd'hui sur notre
territoire
il met des priorités au centre la
solidarité et la santé aujourd'hui
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé en
france régresse ceci ne doit pas être
une fatalité
alors sauver nos rivières faire une
agriculture respectueuse de
l'environnement bio et local c'est un
merci au développement de notre ville
mais si un avion s'il vous plaît votre
conclusion
les 11 et 18 juin les français auront un
choix entre deux visions la première
mondialistes incarné par tous les partis
de droite et de gauche qui de toute
façon appelleront à voter pour le mieux
placé au second tour et la vision parce
que des souverainistes que nous
représentons il est primordial de ne pas
donner tous les pouvoirs à monsieur
macron et à ceux de son gouvernement
madame le lire pour la république en
marche
donc la république en marche avec notre
président secondes pas plus à emmanuel
mâcon c'est effectivement le renouveau
ces trois mots s'est libéré protéger
réconcilier c'est le rassemblement
et c'est aussi protéger quand même des
structures c'est être à l'écouté de tous
les citoyens et c'est faire remonter les
informations des citoyens vers les élus
et non l inverse
7 je trouve que on doit aller dans le
sens de ma et al amel mâcon qui doit
voir la majoritaire si beaucoup car
madame genevard est dans l'opposition va
d'aller chez des partenaires position ne
met rien madame le et voilà la dame
genevard oui au delà des enjeux
bon d'un pas plus oui au-delà des enjeux
nationaux auxquels ma famille politique
celle de la droite et du centre veut
apporter des réponses
moi je vous êtes la députée de ce
territoire du haut doubs et des plateaux
car il ne faut pas les oublier
j'en ai sillonné les 169 commune je le
connais bien ce territoire je laime et
je veux en être à la fois la voix et le
défenseur une france rurale
une france qui est trop peu présente
dans le discours d' emmanuel macron et
je serai fier et très heureuse de
pouvoir à nouveau la représenter la
défendre très bien merci beaucoup aux
hommes et dames merci messieurs donc fin
de ce quatrième et dernier débat
bon dimanche à tous et bonne fin de
journée et on se retrouve dimanche
prochain au revoir